welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is the right honorable raelia omalo
Odinga Prime Minister of the Republic of
Kenya from 2008 to 2013 he was first
elected as the Member of Parliament for
Langara in 1992 served as Minister of
Energy from 2001 to 2002 and as Minister
of roads Public Works and housing from
2003 to 2005 mr. Dingle ran against
incumbent Moy Kibaki into the 2007
presidential election while the results
of that election were largely in
question mr. Kibaki was announced the
winner and mr. Odinga accused mr. Kibaki
of electoral fraud two months of
violence in the country ensued before
Kofi Annan the United States Secretary
General at the time intervened and
brokered a deal that provided for power
sharing between mr. Odinga and mr.
Kibaki and the recreation of the post of
Prime Minister today we'll talk with mr.
Odinga about the state of democracy in
Africa welcome your excellency I think
you think you realize oh I'm happy to be
here good good
there are 54 sovereign countries in
Africa and most of all of them are
members of the United Nations and all
except for Morocco are members of the
African Union how many would you
consider to be full democracies well
it's not what I consider but what the
world generally considers I think they
say that about 22 of these 54 countries
on the continent
certain degree democratic governments to
a certain degree yeah yeah because the
condition in these countries is not a
uniform right it varies from country to
country but as you know that Africa is
in transition right so these are very to
classified as the leaders in the process
of democratization right right and where
does can you fall in that group I think
I can't fault the ending that group just
said lower lower end of it okay yeah so
for the remaining 54 countries what do
you think what are the major obstacles
to democracy taking root in those
countries in Africa well you know there
are areas where there have been
reversions
because you still have the old order
clinging to power that letting go as you
know what do you manage to do following
the the fall of Berlin Wall and the wind
of change that blew in Africa probably
bringing down them single-party and
military dictatorships the those are the
countries where you still have the old
leadership which just refused to let go
participating in elections perfunctorily
but refusing to allow the free and fair
elections in other words they reinvent
themselves they perpetuate themselves
some of them have also refused to accept
the timely limitations when the time
limitation comes they manipulate the
Constitution allow themselves to
continue to
power and is that primarily for economic
reasons I think is more for economic and
personal reasons and they were also
refused to liberalize for example the
society the media freedom is not there
so some of the repressive laws of the
past are still in place in those
countries
okay the youth population in Africa more
than 50% of the population in Africa are
nineteen years or younger in fact it's
Africa is the the has the most
population with the highest rate of
youth do you think that that huge group
can can have any sway in terms of
democracy yes what can they do you know
the youth can be a blessing or a curse
depending on on how you look at it the
young population which is empowered can
be a force for growth and development on
the other hand if the youth is not
empowered then they remain impediments
to economic development because they
will grow into delinquents drug addicts
criminals and so on so we are saying
that this young population in Africa
needs to be empowered so that you can be
able to leave the demographic dividend
like China has done like India's also
done if they are empowered they can
become a serious force for change also
like you saw in the Arab Spring yes
in Tunisia in Egypt and so on if they're
livin attended to they become a major
major force for political
destabilization yes how do you empower
the youth you empower the youth through
skills development that we impart skill
to the youth first you need to make
education accessible and affordable
right from the childhood necessary
primary and high school education and
then also have institutions that will
impart skill to these youths so that
they can become a skilled laborers this
is what China did so that china became
the factory of the world attracting
investors to come into the country to
get industries which requires cheap and
skilled labor force this is my view is
what we need to do in a vector so of the
54 countries and of course only 22 are
our true democracies you know how do you
get education to the youth of those
countries that are not democracies I
mean it seems very difficult yeah first
you know that there are the Millennium
Development Goals we supposed to be
attained by the 2015 I think when the
record was taken it appears as most of
these countries are not going to achieve
the MDGs particularly as far as
education is concerned but I think it is
an issue which a you the African Union I
need to really push we had as far as
education is concerned and so that you
have a common standard one
I believe we need to make the education
as I mentioned accessible from the
Carroll Allen from the nursery school to
primary and then to secondary so that
every child irrespective of his or her
parent social status has access to
quality education like any other child
from primary then you also address the
issue of the transition from at each
level from primary to secondary because
usually have in some country very high
dropout levels at primary and then also
very high dropout at the secondary level
those who don't transition to tertiary
training or universities and because of
that they become basically useless to
society we must address the training at
all those levels that those who don't
make it to the universities have
opportunity to go to tertiary training
institutions they kind of get skills
they can become nurses they can become
technicians and they can become
electricians plumbers as also for that
let's you mentioned the Africa the
African Union and helping with education
how strong is the African Union the
African Union could be stronger okay I
think that the issues we need to address
which they are not addressing such as
what like I just mentioned achievement
of MDGs I think that a you needed to set
up a mechanism through which they can
monitor the performance of its members
in those regards
okay you have a new part of course
which is part of the AU but I don't
think that sufficient emphasis is being
put there that the nations develop
common standards you see
EU is doing that before you become a
memory you your vetted there are certain
specific conditions that you must meet
right before you admitted to the
membership yeah in the AU just a matter
of course so people don't understand why
they should enjoy those privileges I
think that being a member of a you
should have certain obligations
people don't just sit comfortable that
you run a risk of losing your membership
for example if you don't run your
economy in this way or the other way
because in my view we should address the
issue or moving towards economic
integration of Africa like similar to
the EU yes yes and how do you think
other countries would feel about that in
Africa I know that other countries may
not be very comfortable with this but
but I am sure that we should not remain
too complacent as au Rock has been the
case because he was supposed to be an
improvement on the OE u co au was more
or less like a liberation movement which
was formed to continue the process of
liberating Africa from coronary yoke and
appetite well that was achieved then it
was disbanded and formed into we owe you
au
the only you of course did not mind
about what is happening within the in
internally among these member states
there's a clause which was called
non-interference in the internal affairs
of member states so a member state could
violate Human Rights Idi Amin could kill
so many people in Uganda
Mobutu in Congo banned in Malawi
perhaps our intent of the Republic au
was opposed to an improvement because
instead of non-interference there is a
clause which says non indifference to
violation of human rights in each member
state right but that is more in print
than in practice I was going to say no
one seems to be interfering with any of
the violence that are going in on in
some parts of Africa today so I mean
there are a number of issues in Africa I
mean what do you think is the very first
thing that needs to happen to move
toward democracy in those parts in those
countries that are not democratic well
without being specific I think that the
a you need to apply the stick by looking
at the performance of some of those
countries and insisting that certain
conditions must be met
you see we tend to wait until too late
when the war has broken out but when you
find a running left right and center
trying to broker peace but my view is
that you
be proactive so that you can avoid
breakdown of law and order in a country
we just recently you have seen conflict
escalate in Mali in the Central African
Republic in South Sudan each time the EU
gets involved when it is too late
because they are waited until their
secret shall become explosive but one
knows the conditions which eventually
lead to those kind of conflicts so they
need to be addressed much earlier before
the the reach those levels which end up
causing too much suffering to children
to remain until the elderly when the
country is in a civil war so do you have
hope for the future of Africa and
democracy happening someday in your
lifetime in those countries where it
does not happen now yes certainly I've
seen that an afro optimist I believe in
the ability of Africa to rise so despite
the shortcomings and the setbacks that
Africa's experienced in the past I still
am positive that ultimately I will get
there and Africa will actually mobilize
his resources to be able to rejoin the
rest of the humanity so very good thank
you so much for being here with us today
thank you this is a pleasure thank you
for more information about mr. Odinga
please visit our website at yale.edu
slash macmillan report be sure to join
us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale thank you very much